hello everyone and welcome to the
agilent science and technology virtual
symposium
my name is kate pearson santiago and i'm
associate vice president worldwide
marketing
at agilent on behalf of all of the
agilent colleagues
i'd like to warmly welcome you to day
two of our event
yesterday nino tortino agilent vp of
sales
spoke about the ways in which agilent
supports our customers
today i wanted to continue that theme
and share how we are working
to keep you up to date with the latest
product and application
solutions and support offerings
as we navigate changing conditions with
the way we work
we have heard from our customers of the
importance
of educational content at to assist and
adapt to these changes
we aim to be a helping hand albeit a
virtual one
at the moment for the most part and our
recent lab shutdown
and restart webinar series is an example
of this
as you explore the symposium today we
welcome your feedback
either via the survey um or via
speaking with agilent staff in
attendance
we're keen to hear from you about the
topics and issues
of importance to you so that we can
continue to provide
information and insights that support
your needs
customer and employee safety is also
paramount to agilent
and we are increasing ways to connect
with you virtually
as a result this symposium is one
example
of the way that we are replacing many
face-to-face
and virtual trainings and seminars with
digital virtual
and on-demand activities still
like at our live events you still have
the opportunity
to attend live presentations
connect via q a and connect with your
experts and peers
even though it's virtual we are still
here to help and to support you
we're also looking forward to connecting
with you at face-to-face events soon
and you can be assured that when we do
it will be
with the utmost of safety and care
in addition to working towards a safe
environment we are also working towards
sustainability and that's an integral
part of the way that we do business
beyond designing products to enhance
sustainability
we're also aiming to be sustainable in
our operations
for example when we plan live events we
work to minimise
transport and logistics emissions to go
paperless
to minimise single-use plastics as much
as possible
and to provide sustainable giveaways we
know
that many of you and your organizations
have similar
goals and we are equally committed to
improving sustainability with you
and finally staying connected is even
more important in times like this
and agilent provides many opportunities
to connect
via all the major social media platforms
including twitter linkedin and facebook
we have also recently launched regional
specific
social media channels for linkedin and
in local language in thailand
with line so we strongly encourage you
to follow us to keep up to date with
local events and topics
and so finally again welcome we're very
much looking forward to connecting with
you today
and to seeing you in the platform
welcome everyone i'm susie valdez and i
will be your moderator for today's event
and thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled low
energy high confidence untargeted
screening and unknown identification by
high resolution gcms
it's my pleasure now to introduce you to
paul contreras
the project manager for lc time of
flight
and gc quadrupole time of flight at
agilent
technologies for a complete biography on
our speaker please
visit the tab at the top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them into the
q a box and our speaker will address
them
following the presentation please join
me now in welcoming
paul contreras i will now turn the
presentation
over to him welcome paul
hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation my name is paul contreras
product manager for lc toff and gc
qtof at agilent technologies today
i'm going to talk about untargeted
screening and unknowns identification by
high resolution gcms
low energy high confidence agilent gcqs
before we discuss new developments in
the agilent gc qtof portfolio
i'd like to share a brief history of how
the gcq toff came to be
around 2010 agilent recognized there was
a need for a full spectrum
high resolution accurate mass msms
capable instrument in the gc analytical
space
because of agilent's long history in
gcms we were well positioned to leverage
many of the technologies that have been
developed
and refined over the preceding decades
to create such an instrument
the ion source and the gold quartz
quadrupole pioneered in our gcmsd
portfolio
the collision cell that was leveraged
from our leading gc tandem quad
and even the time of flight technology
from our lcms portfolio were all
harmonized into a single platform in
late 2011.
resulting in the 7200 agc qtof the
world's first high-resolution gcq shop
this platform achieved broad market
acceptance across different application
areas
including pesticide and other
contaminants screening in food
and environmental samples metabolomics
profiling
energy and chemical characterization and
more
the 7200a was followed a few years after
by the
7200b which represented a refinement to
the platform with increased
performance specifications and system
robustness
importantly software features were hand
in hand with this platform to help
support targeted qualitative screening
compliant with santi guidelines and to
improve signal processing for high
resolution time of flight data
both of these platforms have proven
themselves analytically especially in
the food and environmental application
spaces
even so we listened to the user
community and recognized the need for an
even greater analytical performance
with that feedback we set out to create
a completely new instrument to expand
performance space for gcms
this new platform was designed to
provide
more confident identification more
accurate quantification
and more powerful exploration
capabilities
this latest platform is the agilent 7250
gc
qtof the instrument may look similar to
the proceeding platforms but underneath
the covers
it's a completely new instrument
one of the differences not fully visible
in this image is the updated
time-of-flight section
we've extended the ion flight path by 50
to increase the resolving power of the
system
which also leads to greater mass
accuracy however improvements in
resolution and mass accuracy
are also made possible by other
technological advances in the system
one of these advances is a completely
new detector electronic system
this new system can digitize ms signals
at up to 10 gigahertz
150 improvement over the previous
generation electronics
what's more this increased detection
rate is possible across two separate
gain channels
part of a significant evolution of the
detector electronics
this results in the ability to acquire
high resolution and
wide dynamic range data simultaneously
from an application perspective
this means significant improvements in
simultaneous qualitative
and quantitative screening are realized
a third piece of brake fluid technology
that was only found on the 7250 gc qtof
that promises to redefine gcms workflows
is a novel low energy electron
ionization source
this ion source based off the high
efficiency source found in the agilent
gcmsd
and gc10 quad instruments has been
optimized for low energy ei operation
with this technology a spectral tilt
towards a compound's molecular ion is
often achievable
through lowering the source ionization
energy
this yields powerful analytical benefits
which we'll cover later
when designing this instrument we wanted
to ensure reliable
reproducible performance to support the
user community needs as high resolution
accurate mass systems move farther into
routine use
the r d teams who designed the
instrument evaluated the components
inside the max
mass spectrometer that have a
significant impact on spectral
performance
and worked to define tolerances to
include
consistent performance from injection to
injection and spectra to spectrum
this is coupled with a completely new
auto tuning algorithm called swarm for
gcq toff
it's a multi-dimensional parameter
optimization routine that allows for
better
more consistent tuning results achieved
in a shorter time frame
of course the gc qtof is partnered with
the world's predominant gc platform the
agilent 8890
this configuration includes a spare
pneumatic switching device channel or
psd channel that can be used to
configure capillary flow technology
devices
such as backflush which is often
recommended for food
and environmental matrices to reduce
analytical runtime
preserve column lifetime and reduce
source maintenance
now let's take a look at some of the
performance characteristics necessary
for confident compound identification
in qualitative gcms here we have a
spectral example from our high
resolution pesticide library showing the
entry for
thiamethoxam thiomethoxam
is restricted in the eu as is as it is a
neonicotinoid
that has been implicated in the decline
of honeybee populations
to identify the presence of this
pesticide there are several criteria
that can be followed
one of the most well known set of
criteria are the usanti guidelines
these guidelines indicate that for a
high resolution
full spectrum instrument like the 7250
gcq toff
at least two ions with a mass accuracy
of better than 5 ppm must be used
with this mass accuracy requirement
changing from a relative measure of 5
ppm for masses above
200m c to an absolute measure of better
than one milli-dalton below
200 m over z
we spiked thiamethoxam at five part per
billion
which is fifty percent of the maximum
residue level to ensure it was
detectable at below regulatory limits
the matrix we chose was avocado since
trace level detection is challenging due
to the background complexity that is
introduced
we then selected two of the
characteristic ions at 182 mass charge
ratio
and 212 m over z
evaluating the spectra for each of these
characteristic ions at trace levels
shows clear separation from nearby
interferences
and excellent max accuracy of 15
millidaltons
for the 182 ion and less than one ppm
for the 212 ion which is in compliance
with the santi guidelines
it's important to emphasize that this
identification is possible in a complex
matrix at 50 percent of the maximum
residue limit
representing a worst case scenario for
identification that
we achieve successfully here with the
7250 gc qtof
mass accuracy has benefits and compound
identification
and it has additional benefits one of
which is replicate precision
to evaluate this performance aspect we
performed a real world application of
looking for trace level contaminant
in a commodity to achieve this we spiked
one
two dibromobenzene into one percent
juniper berry oil
using one percent juniper berry oil as
the example matrix is
a challenging analysis due to large
background levels found in essential
oils
this background level becomes apparent
when evaluating the total ion
chromatogram
which is shown in the center of the
slide we can see
that the baseline is quite elevated with
no readily available gc peaks rising
above the baseline
to evaluate the spiked contaminant we
extracted characteristic ions at about
155 ohms or z
and about 234 m over z as shown in the
library structure
on the upper right hand corner of the
slide
performing extractions of these
characteristic ions show the ion
at about 155 m over z
is able to be extracted cleanly as
is the ion at about 234 m over z
when performing replicate injections we
are able to achieve single digit
percent rsd levels
with a value below seven percent this is
significant because it proves we can
reliably detect a trace analyte not just
once
but consistently across multiple
injections
also notable is the relative difference
in intensity between the total ion
chromatogram
and the each of these extracted ion
chromatograms
which indicates the relative trace level
detection that can be performed on the
7250 gc gcq
while mass accuracy is indeed important
for improving identification confidence
and replicate precision it isn't
everything
this slide that you see here is an
excerpt from a journal publication from
the fiend lab at university of
california davis that discusses one of
the seven golden rules of mass
spectrometry
the rule being discussed here is the
importance of
isotopic fidelity the rule states that a
mass spectrometer with very good mass
accuracy
of less than three ppm but also with
proper isotopic fidelity
will outperform a theoretical mass
spectrometer with near perfect mass
accuracy
of less than 1.1 ppm
when we see outperform we need to limit
the number of candidate molecular
formulae for
a given accurate mass measurement and
restricted element list
as important and as useful as mass
accuracy is there are
diminishing returns to its impact to
illustrate uh how important isotopic
fidelity is to contributing
identification confidence we wanted to
ensure
the 7250 gc qtof retained the excellent
isotopic fidelity found on agilent ms
systems
to illustrate this performance we have
the example of dodecane which might not
be analytically very interesting by
itself
but is often used to calibrate retention
indices for gcms applications
if we zoom on the molecular ion cluster
at mass 170
we can see that the mono-isotopic peak
of the plus-one isotope
and the plus-two isotope nearly
perfectly aligned with the theoretical
isotopic distribution
this gives us an orthogonal degree of
confidence in compound identification
beyond the accurate mass measurement for
the molecular ion cluster
and beyond a gcms spectral library
search
another performance attribute to
consider is the relative trace level of
the molecular ion clusters
as compared to the overall spectral
intensity
the monoisotopic peak for the molecular
ion cluster is about two orders of
magnitude less abundant than the base
ion on the spectra
at 57 m over z and the plus two isotopic
cluster is another two orders of
magnitude less than the molecular ion
peak
despite the trace level of the plus one
and plus two isotope
peaks we see excellent isotopic fidelity
is maintained in this example
since isotopic fidelity is so important
we've built tools into mass hunter data
analysis that allows us to
easily visualize this performance aspect
a simple tool in mass hunter qualitative
analysis allows for the predicted
isotopic distribution
of a putative chemical formula to be
overlaid against a measured spectrum
allowing the analyst to get a quick
visual comparison between the two for
additional confidence
the data shown in this example is a
halogenated phenol
acquired at 50 hertz spectral
acquisition rate
even at very fast acquisition speeds
compatible with comprehensive gc by gc
the 7250 gcq tof is able to maintain
excellent mass accuracy and isotopic
fidelity
even with high resolution accurate mass
measurements and
isotopic fidelity the primary tool for
identification by gcms is still by
library search
this is due to the availability of
hundreds of thousands of reference
spectra and nist
and other commercial libraries most of
which were generated by hp agilent
5790 series scanning quadruple ms
systems
we wanted to ensure that 7250 gc qtof
exhibited the same spectral quality as
these legacy quadruple systems to ensure
maximum utility from the vast multitudes
of
library spectra available the mirror
plot on the slide
shows the pesticide dichlorobus with the
7250 gcq acquired spectra on the top
and the nist library spectra on the
bottom
visually we can see good alignment
between the two spectra
evaluating the library match score we
see that a value of greater than 93 is
achieved for this organophosphate
pesticide
not only can we make use of legacy
nominal mass libraries
but high resolution accurate mass
libraries can also be used for even
greater confidence in spectral matching
an extensible high resolution library of
more than 850 pesticides is available
for the 7250g
qtof another important performance
characteristic to consider is the
instruments in spectrum dynamic range
which is a measure of the limits of
concentration differences between
coaluting compounds
the example on the slide is from a
metabolomics experiment but
we have environmental data on the same
topic we'll share on the next slide to
evaluate the in spectrum dynamic range
of the platform
we will look at a single spectra and
compare the absolute abundance of the
most abundant mass peak with good mass
accuracy
to the least abundant mass peak with
good mass accuracy
for this experiment a metabolite was
detected in a mouse lung extract
the most abundant mass peak at 73 ohm
over z from the derivating agent was
detected at about 4 million counts with
good mass accuracy of less than three
ppm
zooming in on the 414 m over z clock ion
cluster
we can go out to the plus 5 isotope
and see that the 419 m over z ion was
detected
at about 240 counts with a good mass
accuracy
of less than three ppm
[Music]
another example of in spectrum dynamic
range involving an
environmental application is shown here
a combustion experiment was performed to
see the relative change in the amount of
pah
and other compounds before verse after
exposure to a fire event
this is a screen capture of mass hunter
unknowns analysis software which shows
a chromatogram pane in the upper right a
spectral mirror plot in the lower right
and component extracted ion chromatogram
overlays in the center
we can see that the total ion
chromatogram as outlined in the black
trace
in the chromatogram pain is quite
complex with high abundance levels
the extracted ion chromatogram for our
detected component as indicated by the
blue arrow
is dwarfed by the abundance of the total
ion chromatogram the solution time point
despite this vast difference in analyte
first background concentration we can
see from the mirror plot that the 7250
gc qtos spectra
on the top of the mirror plot is
visually extremely similar to the nist
library spectra for the putative
identification of dibromophenyl
ether if we evaluate the library match
score
we can see that it is a value greater
than 95
despite the relative trace level of the
analyte
the spectral match is possible to high
resolution accurate mass detection
with a wide in spectrum dynamic range
but it's also optimized through new
developments
in signal processing which we will
discuss next
those of you who are familiar with
qualitative gcms are likely familiar
with spectral deconvolution
in deconvolution a measured spectra is
evaluated for ions that are present at
significant intensities
these ions are then extracted to create
extracted enchromatograms
extracted ion chromatograms are compared
for chromatographic peak shape and
retention time
and those extracted ion chromatograms
with nearly identical peak shapes and
retention times are grouped together as
a component
the ions associated with these
components are assembled into component
spectrum
and the component spectrum is searched
against the library for compound
identification
this technique works extremely well for
scanning quadrupole mass spectrometers
as that is the analytical platform that
the technique was designed for
while it can also be used for gc qtof
data it doesn't make
use of the information rich high
resolution accurate mass data generated
by gcqdov
this is why agilent has invented
suremass
a new signal processing technique
designed specifically for gc qtof to
optimize analytical results
rather than evaluate data as a set of
static extracted eyeing chromatograms
sure mass considers the data as a
continuous three-dimensional array of
retention time
mass and abundance when visualized in
this manner it becomes clear there are
persistent ridges and features which
correspond to extracted ion
chromatograms
however sure mass processing is able to
extract along the apex of the ridgeline
rather than a static m over z extraction
this
better characterizes the high resolution
accurate mass data that's collected on
the gc qtof
this has a number of benefits
more sensitive detection as sure mass is
able to extract to lower levels than
conventional deconvolution
more accurate mass assignments as mass
accuracy is preserved with this
technique
more accurate abundance measurements
with accurate signal extractions
and more reproducible compound detection
with the processing we are able to
achieve with high resolution accurate
mass
sure mass also has additional benefits
for quantitative measurement which we'll
cover next
[Music]
so let's briefly talk about targeted
quantification with
untargeted acquisition a powerful
combination with the performance
attributes of the 7250 gcq top
to evaluate quantitative linear dynamic
range of this instrument
we spike the pesti pesticide phonophos
into avocado matrix
avocado is a challenging matrix due to
the high amount of lipids and other
heavy background
spiking levels for phonophos started at
0.5 part per billion
which is 20 times lower than typical
maximum residue limit permitted by
regulatory agencies
and is continued all the way up to 1000
ppp
in triplicate when evaluating the
linearity we see
over three nines in the r square valued
in this concentration range
zooming on the low end of the
calibration curve we can see that
between 0.5 ppb
and 50 ppv the curve is still extremely
linear
with no drop off in the low end this
example shows 3.5 orders of magnitude of
linear dynamic range in complex matrix
while maintaining
excellent linearity and consistent
response factors
it's important to keep in mind that
we're looking at data from a full
spectrum
high resolution mass spectrometer in
this example
on a targeted platform like triple quad
each of these calibration points may
represent just a single mrm transition
this provides no additional qualitative
information for the gc qtof
each of these data points is a full
spectrum acquisition meaning we can not
only measure levels against target
compounds
as is shown here we can perform multiple
simultaneous qualitative screening using
high resolution libraries in just one
set of experiments
those suspect compounds which are rarely
detected or for which standards are
expensive or
unavailable are possible to be
qualitatively screened without relying
on a calibration curve
while common targets can be calibrated
against
in a single set of acquisitions on the
7250 gcq top
changing topics we'll now discuss
powerful exploration capabilities for
identification
and elucidation enabled by breakthrough
technology
one of the most challenging tasks for an
analytical lab is the identification of
unknowns
particularly in complex sample matrices
one such example is hydrocarbon analysis
we performed this application
on the 7250 gcq top to evaluate its
performance in this challenging area
injection of a gas oil sample yielded a
typical hydrocarbon chromatogram
as is shown in the upper right hand
corner of the slide
a time segment from this chromatogram
was extracted to generate the spectrum
shown
in the upper left-hand corner of the
slide library search
provided a tentative identification of 3
4
dimethyl benzothiophene which its nist
library spectra is shown below the
chromatic around
although the measured and library
spectra are similar here
there are some obvious visual
differences there is more low mass
fragmentation in the acquired spectra
and it's not quite clear which of the
two molecular ion candidates may belong
to the compound
while we may have some confidence that
this identification has been made
successfully we might
like to see more selectivity in our
detection
it would be very beneficial if we could
produce a cleaner system
with less low mass fragmentation and a
tilt towards the molecular ion
with a relative increase in the
candidate molecular ion to better
identify the compound
ideally we would see almost no
fragmentation
with only a clear molecular ion
candidate rising above the baseline
to increase our confidence in compound
identification we would like the ability
to
preserve or confirm the molecular ion
and also to reduce background signal to
produce a
cleaner spectrum for evaluation on the
7250 gc qtof we were able to generate
both of these spectra by lowering the
ion source energy
first to 15 ev
then to 10 ev how is this possible
through a proprietary low energy ei
source available only on the 7250 gc
qtof
and it's available as standard equipment
there's
nothing that prevents a conventional ei
source from operating a low
electron energy to perform softer
ionization and generate a tilt toward
the molecular ion
although typically this results in
sensitive
sensitivity levels that are just not
usable or
the filaments used burn out extremely
quickly as we have to
increase the electron electron current
to increase the number of low energy
electrons
we've overcome these challenges with a
novel source design based on the high
efficiency source found in the agilent
gc
msd and gc tandem quad models
the source has been optimized for
performance at low energy ei but still
exceeds a conventional 70 eveei
optimizations include a stronger axial
magnet
modified lens geometry and a centered
filament design
all of these changes allow the source to
become even more efficient and
ionization
which allows us to trade some efficiency
for softness and a tilt toward the
molecular ion
although there may be some loss of total
ion current at lower electron energy
values
the efficiency of ionization is still
high enough to provide usable
levels of sensitivity additionally
generated spectra are cleaner
yielding better sensitivity and greater
confidence
an example of low energy ei for
identification goes back to the
previously mentioned metabolomics
experiment
but it also applies universally across
sample types including food and
environmental samples
in the case shown here a tentative
identification of the metabolite
kineranine
was made in a mouse lung extract
while the measured and library spectra
are quite similar
the spectrum was not deconvoluted so
there are some differences
by lowering the electron energy to 17ev
there is a simplification of the
spectrum with a tilt toward the
molecular ion
for this example the candidate molecular
ion experiences
not only a relative increase in
abundance but
an absolute increase as well
at 12 ev the candidate molecular ion
becomes the base ion
since there is an abundance increase of
the candidate molecular ion abundance at
17ev
we can use this as a precursor for
downstream msms experiments
because the 7250 gc qtof is an msms
capable instrument
it can generate product ion spectra
once a precursor has been isolated and
fragmented the product ion spectrum can
be opened in agilent's molecular
structure correlator
msc software for analysis
the product ion spectra are evaluated
not only for mass information
but fragment information as well
molecular structure correlator uses
online services like pubchem
and chemspider to pull down candidate
formula and structures for masses in the
product ion spectra with associated
likelihoods
providing the analyst insight into not
only chemical formula but
compound structure as well the previous
example highlighted a case where a
proposed id was made by library match
and it was compared with low energy ei
and msms for
an independent degree of compound
identification
but what happens when a library search
returns a poor match or
no match at all in this case the sample
contains a true unknown
and the analytical capabilities of the
system must be used to provide guidance
on the identity of the compound
this data shows a chromatogram and
spectrum from an unknown compound
detected in an extractables and
leachables experiment that was evaluated
on the 7250g
qtof where the unknown compound was
detected at retention index
1711 with no library match returned
to investigate the compound the sample
was additionally acquired at 10ev
this resulted in a clean spectrum with
less low mass fragmentation and a tilt
toward the high mass region
from this data two candidate molecular
ions were identified
with each of the candidate ions
identified ms ms experiments were
scheduled to isolate each precursor to
generate product ion spectra
candidate 1 was the precursor at mass
191
while candidate 2 was the precursor
at mass 220. with the product ion
spectra now available
each of the characteristic masses in the
original ms only spectra were compared
to the product ion spectra
in doing so it becomes clear that
candidate 2 contains much of the
characteristic ions
and in approximately the same proportion
as the ms only spectra
if we consider the relative similarity
of the ms only spectra
and the msms product ion spectra of our
220
m over z precursor we have some
confidence that we've selected the
correct precursor ion comparing the mass
accuracy with the candidate formula we
have additional confidence in the
identification
and looking at the isotopic pattern we
have
additional independent confidence in the
chemical formula determination
with the product ion spectrum from the
candidate molecular ion the molecular
molecular structure correlator can be
used to propose candidate fragment
structures and likelihoods
leading the analyst to narrow the list
of possibilities
in this extractables and leachables
experiment the candidate
unknown is a benzene methanol derivative
which can be further confirmed by
comparison with a purified reference
standard
if available
we've gone through the case of not
having a library hit to propose
a compound identity however the majority
of non-target screening cases will
return a library hit
it is up to the analyst to determine the
validity of the match
in this area the gcmsd used with
deconvolution and library searching
is a very practical choice the gc msd
presents a great value for both
qualitative and quantitative work
there's a reason we sell so many sds and
have done so for decades
and yet there are cases where even the
venerable gc
msd needs a little support let's go
through one such example
covering an untargeted screening of
broccoli
after data acquisition and deconvolution
the component list is evaluated
our first example is a component that
elutes at right around
5.6 minutes
the high resolution accurate mass
spectrum closely matches the niss
spectrum for the compound 2 6
dimethyl naphthalene with a score of
94.7
with a gcmsd this is where our analysis
would end
with the gc qtof we can perform low
energy ei
to gain further confidence that the
proposed molecular ion at 156 m over z
is likely the correct choice and the
accurate mass measurement corresponds to
a 0.3 ppm mass error
with the proposed compound formula
two additional degrees of confidence
that the identification is correct
but this still provides the same answer
as the gcmsd
a little further down the component list
a
library match of 137 trichloronephylene
is made with a score
of 87.2 not quite as compelling as the
previous example but still quite good
with visually similar spectra between
the gcq top and nist
again low energy ei confirms that we
likely have the correct
molecular ion identified when comparing
the accurate mass measurement of this
molecular ion
to the library compound formula we find
a problem though
a mass error of over 100 ppm
immediately the library search is put in
doubt
we now need a way to determine what this
compound likely is
exactly the task for what the 7250 gcq
top was built
we'll need to dig deeper into our
example to figure out just what this
compound is
after confirming the candidate molecular
ion with low energy ei
a product ion spectrum is generated
the fragment masses in the product ion
spectrum match those in the ms only
spectrum
providing further confidence that the
molecular ion selection is correct
with this product ion spectrum the
molecular structure correlator tool
can then be used to propose likely
structures for the molecular ion
and fragments
with this approach the compound 2 4 5
trichloroisothalon
is exposed importantly this compound is
not in nist
which is why the gcmsd would not have
picked this up in library search
but this is reported as a pesticide
degradation product
although commercial libraries are
extremely useful the added features of
accurate mass data
low energy ei and full spectrum msms
capability make the 7250 gcq toff
the qualified choice for investigation
and tentative identification of unknown
compounds
we've now seen that the venerable gcmsd
is an excellent screening tool
but the limitation of unit mass spectra
leave room for doubt
[Music]
for complete confidence and unknown's
identification the 7250 gcq top is a
platform of choice by those who know
gcms
the analytical capabilities of the 7250
gcq top solution
provides answers where only more
questions were previously raised
in this presentation we've shown quite a
few examples of data
but data itself is of limited value
without the necessary tools to generate
meaningful results
in applications like screening mass
hunter data analysis tools
in both qualitative and quantitative
analysis allow for seamless
integrated screening against nominal and
high resolution spectral libraries
and reference standards in one set of
experiments
for profiling experiments mass hunter
profinder and unknowns analysis
allow for high throughput compound
detection which drives
multivariate statistical studies in mass
hundred profile professional
for different analysis with optional
workflows for compound identification
and or biologic pathway
contextualization
investigation of unknowns is enabled
through mass hunter qualitative analysis
pro finder and unknowns analysis with
deeper insight possible through msms
data
in molecular structure correlator
software
for compound class prediction
statistically trained models can be
generated through mass profile or
professional
to offer predictive insight on future
sample sets
the whole suite of mass hunter data
analysis applications enables users of
agilent ms instrumentation to make sense
of the information-rich data
generated by platforms across the lcms
and gcms domain
a common set of software tools enables
analytical chemists
to maximize their productivity across
the agilent ms portfolio
that brings us to the end of our
presentation
as we've shown the performance
characteristics of the all new 7250 gc
qtof promise to move gcms analysis
forward across
identification quantification and
exploration workflows empowered by
comprehensive software tools
designed with feedback from the user
community and optimized for real world
samples and applications
the 7250gc qtof strives to equip
analytical labs with the tools necessary
to solve challenging gcms analysis
today and into the future
thank you all for your time and
attention this concludes the
presentation
thank you paul for that outstanding
presentation and we will now
move to the q a live portion of our
presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q
a box paul it looks like we already have
quite a few questions coming in from our
audience members
our first question how would all
ion workflow work for agilent's gc
qtof platforms and what is the
downstream
data processing like
sure that's a great question thanks
susie um
for those not familiar with the all ions
workflow as used on the
lc uh quadruple time of flight
instruments it's a
full scan workflow where precursors are
then identified for targeted msms
experiments
on the gc qtof and was mentioned
in my in my presentation uh we utilize
the uh low energy ei source um
to do this uh of course we can schedule
targeted msms methods uh with the gcq
top as well
and then brought into mass hunter
acquisition
or sorry a mass hunter data analysis
software in order to
identify those targeted precursors but
again reiterating what was mentioned in
the presentation
by using the source to identify
precursors for
a targeted method we can optimize the
sensitivity
um and the power of a library
in order to identify precursors perform
targeted experiments
and to ultimately find
the compound ids that we that we that we
would like with that workflow
thank you so much and can data collected
on the
7250 be matched with unit mass
libraries yes of course it can
so mentioned also was the sure mass
deconvolution
uh and with the deconvolution uh with
the accurate mass data
we can then utilize the unit mass
library not just an accurate mass
library
this is one another such example where
we can do so
to leverage that data
for a more versatile analysis
thank you very much we have time for one
more question
it is mentioned that low energy el
source is standard equipment are other
sources offered for the 7250
sure yes uh as i i had mentioned the low
energy ei source
um is a combined source so it can run
low energy ei
and standard ei but we do also
offer a chemical ionization source uh it
is capable of both positive
and negative chemical ionization and
utilizes uh
methane as the carrier gas there so um
we do have the versatility of multiple
sources for use on the instrument and
this
is something that was offered shortly
after release of the instrument but is
available now
as as an option
paul i want to thank you for your
presentation today and also for your
important research
and i also want to thank the audience
members for their outstanding questions
any questions that were submitted and
not answered today
by our speaker will be answered via your
email address
and the presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing through september
2021.
please share that with a colleague who
may be interested in today's topic
thank you again for your participation
and i hope you will join me for our next
presentation
vincent balloon if you are not moving
into the new
virtual studio take care be safe until
next time
bye-bye thanks again paul
thank you